Grab your life jackets and VHS copies of neverending story
Because we have the biggest show about taking down Russians since commando.
Wait that movie doesn't involve Russians
Stranger things season 3 is back and with it a whole new ending to unpack
so in this video
We're gonna take a deep dive into what the hell happened in Hawkins and what its events could mean for season 4
So grab a breath mint
Because here we go
The biggest shocker for the end of the season is the apparent death of Jim Hopper
But did he actually die. The show actually leaves a few clues that hint at how and where Jim might have gone
Exhibit A as the electromagnetic beam is about to explode check out this shot
This is right before the Russians in their hazmat esque type suits get vaporized
No, hopper Exhibit B in episode 6 the Russian scientist choice in hopper hold hostage
Alexei gives some clues that may help bring attention
There are many of these before
The key he's referring to are these big-ass laser beams aptly named because they unlock the doors to other worlds
Just like a key you're using this energy
emotions price was breakthrough
To open a doorway
A doorway between worlds
If there are many of these keys as he calls them and they act as channels between worlds is it not possible then?
Hopper was somehow transported to a the upside down or B
One of the other Russian facilities in the post-credits scene
We see the Russians in Kamchatka
Seen here have been successful at opening another one of these portals after all how would they have acquired this deme Gorgon?
But it's what the russian soldier says here that leaves the biggest unanswered
question no
not the American the most likely person behind that door is
Hopper who likely got captured by the Russians while he was in the upside down or through some sort of?
Teleportation via the key. Of course Joyce doesn't know that hopper could potentially be alive in the last episode
She tells him that she might just stay in Hawkins even agreeing to go on a full-on date with him to Enzo's. How's your Chia Tea?
-
But with him now gone in the town believing he died in a tragic fire Hawkins has nothing left for the Byers family
It's been nothing but a place of pain for them and with choices only reason to stay gone hopper
It's time to move on Joyce and hopper are also two characters who share well-crafted character arcs Joyce starts off the season
Unwilling to move on with her life after the death of her boyfriend, Sam Gamgee, I mean Bob Newby
She's still haunted by his death and skirts hoppers advances even forgetting to meet up for their date at Enzo's
She didn't even want to call it a date contrast that to the Joyce we see at the end
She is the one to ask Hopper out and literally moves on with her life in a moving van. Hopper's arc
However has more to do with his relationship with El
He's the overprotective father who refuses to let his daughter grow up going so far as to
Intimidate Mike, maybe by the end of it. Maybe if you're lucky maybe I
will continue
To allow you
to date
My daughter as hopper tells El.
As Hopper tells El, His biggest fear is change that shall one day change in the girl
He knew who used to eat Eggos and laugh watching westerns with him the girl that made him happy
Will one day find someone else
It's the fear that many fathers go through but hopper can't seem to let it go
That is until the final episode where he extends this olive branch to Mike who's going to take care of Elle
Be careful
Hopper's realizing he won't always be there for her and his acceptance of mike is a big leap from the hopper we saw in episode
one nod if you
understand
L goes on her own journey this season battling the main villain the mind flayer and struggling with her own relationship
I dump your ass! Like hopper says she's a young woman who is changing experiencing new things
This is encapsulated in episode 2 when Maxine takes Elle out to experience the mall
It's like a child seeing candy for the first time. How do I know I
like you just try things on but besides navigating her relationship with Mike the end of the season sees a giant change for
Elle both externally and internally
She's lost the closest thing. She has to a family hopper as well as her power
But is her power gone for good
Before the Battle of Star Court, she tells hopper that her power is like a battery
It just needs to be recharged, but three months later
She still hasn't regained her powers
Some theorized that when L was bitten by the mine flare part of the slug creature inside her sapped her of her power
But I don't necessarily agree for one
She was still able to destroy the Russians by flipping over a car after she was bitten. So what happened?
It's likely a combination of two things
One during the battle
She was likely spent of all her energy having spent most of it in episode 7 fighting off the mine flare and hoppers cabin
Second we know that Elevens powers are closely linked to her emotions in the past
She's used her powers when frightened or angry three months later
We find her still struggling with the most traumatic event of her life the death of hopper
English
She's also moving with the buyers having to say goodbye to her boyfriend and starting a new life
It's all extremely stressful and no doubt has an impact on her powers
My guess is when L finds out. Hopper is still out there
It will either help reignite her powers or take her on a quest to rekindle them
But let's take a moment to talk about the main villains of the season
We have the mind flayer Billy the Russians and to a lesser extent
mayor
klein near the end of the season the kids
discovered that the mind flayer a creature from the upside down which took control of will last season has been trapped in Hawkins when L
Close the portal at the end of the season
But with will no longer the host the mind flayer had to look for someone new
Eventually setting up shop at the abandoned steel mill where he takes over Billy's body for most of the season
The mine flare is too weak to fight Elle and uses Billy to recruit more flares as they're called to his side
This includes mrs
Driscoll and many of the townspeople who eventually disintegrate into piles of goo to morph into the mind flayers
physical form the only thing stopping the mine flare from taking complete control over the world is l
Which is why Billy spends most of the time saying?
He's referring to the giant mine flare goop creature which gains more and more strength as it acquires more
Townspeople, but we need to talk about Billy breath struck
Last season I hated him not because he was a villain but because he seemed to be a dick just for the sake of being
A dick his actions were thinly motivated as to why he turned out the way he did in this season
however
The writers have created an empathetic Billy one haunted by the trauma of his past which reveals why he's such a dick in the first
place when L uses her special powers to delve into Billy's memories
Which she's only used once before with her mother last season we get a better glimpse of what makes Billy Billy
She sees his mom and younger self at the beach one of his favorite memories
Which is juxtaposed with his abusive father
And him being taken away from his mother as L ventures further down this Beach the storm around her
Intensifies as Billy's memories get increasingly violent Billy lashes out at others because it's his way of taking out his childhood
Frustration he asserts his power over others because he had no power at home
But Billy goes through a redemptive arc at the end of the season when he's about to kill L
She talks to him about his favorite memory of his mother
This allows him to break out of the mind flayers control and save l at the last minute
Sacrificing himself just long enough for Joyce tiss shut down the key and destroy the mine player for good
But this comes at a cost Billy's life and honestly
I thought this was a great choice by the writers in the fan community season 2 Billy was seen as one of the most unlikable
Characters but now they've done two things gotten rid of him while actually making me care about him
It's a proper send-off to a character who probably didn't have much more to contribute to the show
anyway
We also have the Russians who are the narrative thread which linked the entire season
Into the next not only does this season start with the Russians
It ends with them too hinting that season four will delve further into the u.s
versus Russia Cold War undertones
the Russians are looking for ways to gain power and assert dominance over the US and what better way than harnessing the
Interdimensional powers that these keys seem to unlock as alexei said there are many of these keys
But that's only half the equation. The other is location
One of these locations just happens to be Hawkins
Indiana another
Kamchatka Russia, if the Russians could somehow weaponize the deme Gorgons and or control the upside down
it may just be the thing that could win the Cold War and
finally
We have slimey mayor Cline played by the guy from saw or Princess Bride
If you want something more uplifting Cline was responsible for selling Hawkins land to the Russians and ends up behind bars on corruption charges
So with the bad guys defeated in our characters venturing off in two different locations
What does this mean for season four first? We have the question of choice el Jon and will leaving town
It's never mentioned in the show where exactly they're going, but it's far enough that Mike and Al can only meet during the holidays
So how will this play out one theory suggests that next season we'll see several storylines set in different cities
We had one episode like this last season where L ventured on our own in search of her mother
But this season would see half the cast in Hawkins and half in a yet unknown location
Mike also says that he'll have Dustin's radio hooked up
So they'll be able to communicate whenever they want to and if two locations weren't complicated enough
we also have hopper in Russia a second theory is that some event will force el and the buyers back to Hawkins and if there's
Any event that would cause that it would likely involve hopper and it's possible that next season may take place entirely
During one of these holidays that way we'd get all the characters back in Hawkins without having to deal with them hundreds of miles apart
In the last episode we also get a brief glimpse of dr
Sam Owens who played a more prominent role in season two
He's a high-ranking member of the US Department of Energy who also is responsible for helping
Hopper and arranging the adoption of eleven the fact that we see him for the last episode after being non-existent
this entire season hence that season four will likely involve the US government as the plot of the Russians has now been discovered and
Covered up by the US government now I could do a whole other video on all the other characters and their arcs during the show
Especially our beloved dusty buns, but in this one, I just wanted to cover the main points involving the ending
however, if you want more stranger things videos
Shoot me a comment or send me a message on Twitter Epting story YT. Make sure to LIKE and subscribe
I have more videos on the way and remember daddy loves you very much